this is from the gainesville times so as
a gainesville woman says she was
threatened at a waffle house on november
7th by employees who said they needed
nooses after her biracial family walked
in to eat
um while at the waffle house in
gainesville uh a a woman angelica tabor
fells
recorded a video describing the
allegations which has since gone viral
and tick-tock with 2.5 million views
um of course and so there's you know
this has already gone viral the the
police department is investigating it
the waffle waffle house has released a
statement it's a whole thing
let's watch we have the tick tock video
here is what's her name angelica
taborfels
with a story of a noose related hate
crime these things are always okay up
until this moment and we'll watch it
together and we'll see what we think
about it but up until this moment
these stories have always been false
i mean like 100 of the time for the last
30 years at least anytime there's a
claim of a noose related hate crime or a
racist incident involving a noose it is
always false every time it's incredible
that we have that i mean
to bat a thousand on something like this
is pretty incredible uh but maybe this
will be different maybe this is the one
real one
the one real incident
let's watch and find out
so we're at waffle house in gainesville
i've 129.
look at my family it's very diverse
so i'm about to show you a waitress that
decided to ask for a noose
in front of me and my daughter
and then when i asked to speak to the
manager the manager who said that he has
two nooses in his car
so i'm pretty dag on shore this is
probably the racist place i've ever been
[Music]
now they're trying to hide ma'am can i
get my um ticket to go because miss
thing over there needs a noose and we're
the only black people in here
and your manager said he got two nooses
in his car so we're getting the hell up
out of here
and i need a number for corporate
[Music]
okay
uh i mean i don't mean to laugh at your
pain um miss angela angelico angelo
whatever your name is
uh i i just angelico's name
yeah i i i find this extremely hard to
believe i really do
so
some customers walk in
and the waitress looks at them and says
i gotta grab my nooses
and the manager says i gotta fuel my car
go grab
what
it doesn't even make any sense what like
okay did she say oh i need to get some
juice i mean can we go through words
that rhyme with noose here
so of course as we said batting a
thousand these stories are always fake
uh and i gotta say this one
this this one i would put on the tier of
uh the claim a couple years ago that
there were new racist nooses hanging
from a um
at a cracker barrel that someone had put
there and then it turns out that they
were just chords like extension chords
so i would say i'm going to give this a
99.9999999 percent chance of being false
let's just
let's
let's round up and call it 100
these stories are always fake and i'm
thinking this one's going to be no
exception
uh you know there there are if we wanted
to to break this down and analyze it
there are a number of questions we could
ask probably no reason to do it but
here's one question
why would they be the first black people
at this waffle house to have this
experience
i mean if this waffle house is that
racist that you simply walk in and they
start talking about going to grab a
noose um wouldn't there be other
customers who would have similar stories
or are we supposed to believe that these
are the first black customers that have
ever gone into this waffle house are we
really supposed to believe that
waffle house in gainesville is never has
never seen a black customer before
that's a you know i'm not look i'm a big
fan of waffle house by the way
assuming that they're not committing
hate crimes like this if they are then i
will not go on any more waffle houses
but
uh on the assumption that they're not
i'm a big fan of waffle houses myself um
and i consider myself to be sort of
aficionado of waffle houses and what i
will tell you is uh one of the great
things about it is waffle houses are
very very diverse um i i've never been
to a waffle house that was anything less
than racially diverse i just that that's
another thing that makes this story not
make a lot of sense hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated